Okay, perfect. Now we're official.
Sounds good.
Cool. So first thing, do you go by Melody or a short version of your name?
I love it. Actually, that's the first time anyone's ever asked me that. So I go by Mel,
but really my family calls me that professionally. Now most people just call me Melody.
But I also answer to RT, Hey you, that random person over there. Anything like that.
Melissa, Melanie, you know, anything that's remotely an M name. So, but Mel is great too.
Whatever you want to call me is good.
Perfect. We'll go with Mel then.
And what do you prefer? Like Ryan's pretty short, so it's not.
Yeah, Ryan doesn't have any like shortened version, so Ryan is totally fine.
Okay, sounds good.
Cool. Yeah, I guess we got in touch because you have a page on Instagram that does like
education about respiratory therapy stuff. And I think I found out about it from Mike
at the World's Okayist Medic podcast. Because I think you chatted with him or he like re-shared
something of yours and you have a book that you published that's available for free on
like mechanical ventilation. Yeah.
What's the story with that? I'm curious to know like why you put a book out for free
and mainly because everyone always asks me the same question.
Yes, because I know of your book and I actually knew of your book before. Kudos by the way.
I love it. It's amazing. It's much higher level. It gets into more of the weeds than I didn't mind.
But I'll get into that in a second. I do want to just shout out to Mike because
Crunch definitely was the reason I even started Instagram. He like had me on his podcast just
because he thought I was funny when I messaged him on Instagram. And it started a beautiful
friendship and then he kind of pushed me annoyingly hard and I finally like ripped the band-aid and
started my Instagram page. But prior to that, just like around COVID, I was looking around
for different mechanical ventilation books. And at that time I hadn't seen yours. And I had seen
like books for ventilation that were written by paramedics. And I had seen, of course,
there's textbooks written by physicians, but I didn't really see anything that was written by
an RT. And I was like, you know, there really should be an RT voice in this because I think
being a non-physician designation, we have an expertise in ventilation, but also a way
to maybe simplify the concepts and bring it down from maybe a physician level or intensivist level
where they might get into more of the studies and the research and be able to explain things
in language that's easy to understand. And also coming from a standpoint from respiratory therapy
with our background and being in a hospital and being very immersed in best practice medicine,
kind of moving out of maybe some of the practices. And I don't want to come off as
speaking down to any profession because that's not it at all. But sometimes when you have a silo of
paramedics teaching paramedics or nurses teaching nurses, you don't necessarily get a complete
picture of best practice when it comes to ventilation. So and I had seen a little bit of
that specifically with my hate on for SIMV that I'm always very honest about, that I would see
that a lot in books that are written by paramedics of still teaching it as a mode that's used quite
heavily. So anyways, all that to say, I wanted to have a voice as an RT to be able to speak to
those professions that don't necessarily have mechanical ventilation in their bread and butter
of their profession and be able to explain it in a way that's easy to understand and within one book,
take someone from nothing and give them the building blocks to be able to initiate ventilation
in a situation where they don't necessarily have expertise at the bedside like a critical care
paramedic or like a physician or an RT to be safe and to not harm someone and be able to pick
settings that were appropriate for their patient and potentially even the therapy like non-invasive
versus invasive and the mode of ventilation and they might not necessarily be at the level of a
critical care provider but be safe. So I wanted it to be simple, easily digestible and within a very
short period, get them to at least initiating safe settings and then moving through why you
would make changes based on gases and things like that. So that was kind of where I came up with the
idea of having an RT voice to do that and I started just writing it while I was flying on
like longer halls just in the back of the aircraft while I was flying and then I had
a wonderful resource that actually I sent the book to them and they loved it and saw the value and
merited it and sent it to someone that they knew who actually was connected with Stu College
which is a college here in Canada and they actually sponsored and partnered with me to get it
a grant for it to be able to release it free and that's kind of how it happened and why I decided
to write it and I wanted to write it free to get it out because I wanted there to be absolutely no
barriers to any person regardless of their background, regardless of their familiarity
with events to at least have something to start their journey and to start their journey in a way
that isn't overwhelming or scary. Is that group Stu? Do they run the like the book is published
on this website that like makes it pretty easy to read online like versus mine that's just like a
PDF document but do they run that website as well like how does how did the hosting part of it work?
Yeah so the way that the grant that they they helped me get the grant Stu College so they're
an accredited college here in Canada but the the grant actually is through the Ontario government
and so they have an online publication database that is an open educational resources which is
what the grant was for and it was pretty much any educational resource it didn't have to be medical
it could be anything else could apply for a grant and I had to write a proposal and the rationale
and the reason why and I honestly think COVID was worked in my favor because it was right at the
time when COVID was coming up and ventilation actually was something that the public knew about
and they heard about it on the news and when I pitched it to them I said this is this is to
increase the expertise of multiple disciplines to be able to understand mechanical ventilation and
I think those magic words were what really helped in the world of COVID to get them to be able to
say like yes we will we we will publish this and we will publish it for free so it's it published
open source and with that copyright it can be used by anyone but if they use the material they
have to then publish open source as well so it actually locks people into a gift that keeps giving
so they can use it they can use all the content but if they want to they have to then publish
for free as well right on yeah that's cool that's kind of my long long drawn-out story but yes
for sure yeah and I imagine that was like ideal timing because I imagine it was the same for you
guys up there but like here in the states we had a lot of clinicians who don't typically use
ventilators or who were using ventilators that they're not used to working with like during that
time because we just had so many patients so I think like having a resource like that probably
helped out a lot cool and you mentioned this in your narrative about like how you started the book
but you also fly not anymore so I flew for for four years so now I work for a critical transport
company here in Canada but actually the company that I work for is only paramedic based it is
like actually one of the sole companies that I'm aware of that has a paramedic paramedic pairing
so it's two ccp's that fly instead of like a paramedic nurse or physician nurse or physician
paramedic like other services so I work for them and I'm one of their educators and I do a lot of
their mechanical ventilation airway respiratory teaching for all their ccp's and I absolutely
love it right on and you still work in a hospital as well or just the you do yeah I do so I'm
actually an anesthesia assistant and I'm an RT so mostly when I work clinically I now work as an RT
but I still am an anesthesia assistant and I did work in the OR as an A for a while but now
mostly my clinical shifts are just RT. Cool right. Well you and I have been talking a fair amount
about like all things mechanical ventilation but I think you've seen this list as well but I kind
of put a list of questions together to ask you about I don't know if we'll have time to get
through all of them but maybe we'll just dive into those and see where it takes us. Absolutely
whenever you're ready. All right I'm ready so the first thing that I was curious and it was like
what do you think is the maybe not the biggest difference what are like some of the differences
between how mechanical ventilation is done or taught in the hospital setting versus how it's
done or taught in the transport setting. I honestly think the main difference
there's there's not that many differences in a good program but I think the main difference is
as an RT or in the hospital environment our main ideology when it comes to ventilation is minimizing
the time on the ventilator. There is we're not a bridge to anything we're not getting a patient
somewhere like once a patient is intubated every single action and thing that I do is to get them
off that ventilator and that's what I see my job is as an RT it's not to intubate people or to manage
ventilators it is to get people off of them so when it comes to a normalized gas I'm weaning that
patient when the patient has a spontaneous drive to breathe I'm considering a spontaneous mode
immediately. There is really not a place to put paralytics in for safety or to sedate people for
safety because you don't need to do that if they're breathing or they have a drive to breathe you make
them comfortable in the vent you decrease asynchronies and you get them off the ventilator
versus in transport you know safety is paramount we are moving the patients around and it does shift
the mindset a bit that yes if I have a normal gas I'm probably not going to wean my patient I'm
probably going to let that ride and I'll probably leave my patient deeper and not have them lighter
with their sedation because I'm not necessarily weaning them to extubate when I know I'm about to
take them out of the aircraft in a minute and disturb them so I would honestly say that's
probably the main difference just by nature of it being in transport that even when I was flying
I was the same way that I didn't I wasn't necessarily as aggressive. I know yeah that makes sense.
What do you think? Do you see any differences in your in your? I do I mean I think we'll probably
get into some of these but I think yeah I think your take on it makes a lot of sense that your
the idea of like ventilation is like you're always working to get something off like in
the hospital where I work every time we come on shift whether it's day shift or night shift
we're always doing an SAT and if they pass it they won't do an SPT and we'll try and get them
off the ventilator as soon as possible that's like always something on our to-do list.
I think there's a lot of little things that are different in like how we teach it in transport
versus like in the hospital like we spend a lot of time in transport talking about like some very
like nuanced specific things and like I think at the hospital side of things they tend to have like
a the approach like maybe those little tiny things don't matter like for example like in pre-hospital
setting at least where I work really big on like quantifying everything in mechanical ventilation
whereas in the hospital side they're like I don't know just put them on settings and we'll run a gas
and then if we need to adjust it we can and I don't think there's like a right or a wrong it's
just like a different approach. Yes I actually like that you brought that up and I know one of
the questions you had sent me was about like the gestalt of a bedside RT or position of like just
kind of almost feeling your way through ventilation you throw them on a setting you see the volumes
they're getting and then you're making changes but you're not necessarily calculating or looking at
totally the minute ventilation and like targeting specific numbers and like I am a big proponent of
the art and the science and those two things together and I do not I do definitely see within
you know working with paramedics so closely and working with with RNs closely that yes like they
want a number to hold on to and they want something to really look at but I always
I always try to remind them that like those numbers aren't necessarily accurate like then
you have to dive in and dig deeper like you can't see the metabolism of the patient you can't see
the vq matching specifically unless you're doing a metabolic study to see how how those numbers
in that minute ventilation is really going to refer to co2 clearance so then like you're
guessing you're still at that point guessing and yes maybe you're calculating you know with this
minute ventilation and this co2 then I'd have to increase my minute ventilation by this but then
I would argue why not improve your your dead space to actual alveolar ventilation ratio a bit better
improve your vq mismatch and then once you do that you'll be more effective so there is always
a bit more hand waving I think than most people would like it to be when it comes to ventilation
but like as long as you're moving in the right direction like I don't care if you want a number
we can go with numbers and and I do uh when I do my training if they want numbers to look at then
I show them all the different calculations they can do because I know that some people like that
when they're learning to have that safety yeah that's kind of how I've like where I've arrived at
like where I work like they're really big on numbers so like in the workplace like I
we calculate everything out and realistically a lot of times you're like calculated after the fact
like in like when I'm teaching somebody I'd say like here's like how you would get all the numbers
if you had no idea where to start but in reality like if you're like looking at a patient on the
ventilator like if everything looks good if you like do your normal patient assessment stuff
and like everything checks out like just match those settings and then and then adjust from there
or if you're like starting like let's say you did the RSI just like put them on the defaults that
your machine goes to and then like adjust from there I think that's totally fine to do yeah as
long as you're not like you know like putting a kid on the adult defaults or whatever like
within reason of course and then like when you have a moment you can always like do
the math and like get your numbers and then like see how it compares yeah absolutely like I always
love you know teaching people when you're throwing someone out in a pressure control mode like picking
a pressure control of 15 it might seem like you're just picking a number out but then there's
actually science behind that it's like okay if you know if your pressure control is 15 then you're
driving pressure is less than 15 so you're already safe there and if you're in you know volume
ventilation you can pick you can do the calculation for further predictive body weight and like again
I always like again so I like have my soap boxes again like I always say measure your patient like
get your volumes and know your safe volume ranges and then put those in and then yeah when it comes
to your respiratory rate to go with it like I always preach demographic norms because I'd
rather have the information back from the vent to know how they're exhaling and whether there's gas
trapping and things like that before I start to go beyond that so I might know that I might be
titrating it up but I'm not necessarily gonna you know go calculate straight out and say I need to
have a respiratory rate of 27 in order to get this patient to clear co2 like I'm not going to
start there I'm going to start lower but yeah how often are you or artes in general in your system
actually getting a tape measure out and measuring patients do you think
less than they should yeah I mean same for us too yeah like I can't measure in my pocket on the
flight suit but like almost nobody does I know I um like I even sometimes I'll tell people like it
doesn't have to be difficult like make the good choice easy whenever I work a clinical shift and
oh my goodness don't tell them that my artes I do this because I hope they think it's just a fairy
but I actually tape the disposable tape measures to every single ventilator that's circuited so when
it gets wheeled into the room it's right there but if you make that choice easy then they do it
but like yeah I'll be honest there are times oh sorry I didn't mean to stop on you there but
there are times that like I don't have a measuring tape close by but I know that my arms band is my
height so sometimes I'll use that as an estimate before I can go grab it and then measure um but
yeah it's not as much as they should for sure yeah totally yeah I was just gonna make a comment
that like lowering that like barrier to doing the thing makes sense like I said the same thing when
I'd say it kind of ingests but seriously like if I set you up for an intubation like if I'm your
partner like I'm gonna take the stylet out of the ET tube and I can't do a bougie like I just like
I'm gonna set you up for success like that way you don't have a choice like you just like use
a thing that gives you better success um yeah so I think like taping a tape measure
to the machine makes sense um yeah I would compare it maybe to like estimating
weights on patients for drug doses like I think we think we're pretty good at it
but we're probably not so like it makes sense just like take a moment to measure somebody
yeah I I really really suggest it because I'll be honest my my mental math especially in times
of crisis is never as good as I think it is so I I've been off some crazy times in my career
where I'm like oh they're probably around six foot and they're like not anywhere near that and I'm
like let's see it's hard to tell sometimes for sure yeah especially when you have like a patient
like bundled up or like a bunch of things piled on them and equipment it's like kind of hard to tell
not to jump back in the conversation but you mentioned like some differences in transport
versus hospital and like um one thing that I have appreciated so much in in my career is um
changing and moving to transport from a hospital environment and having other health um health care
disciplines teach me that like especially when it came to airway and like the OR did a lot to teach
me but I appreciated so much the like how you said like the making the best choice like the first
choice and that like setting yourself up for every single patient that you have the worst case scenario
at your forefront and like in the OR we're good at that but that's something that I would say
as a profession I don't see as much as I'd like to see within respiratory therapy when it comes to
airway management that they don't tend to set themselves up using you know dash 1a success
for like airways and really thinking about like the concerns for hypotension and hypoxia and like
I even using passive oxygenation methods during their intubation and that for ems that's probably
horrific because that was years and years ago that that was brought into practice but I I still find
I think they have ways to go and to move and to improve in that area and I've appreciated so much
how I've been taught in that way that I I I follow I think I I feel like I'm a blend of
professions now from the the amazing growth that I've had from different like from paramedics and
nurses within working with them in the past so it's been it's been really amazing for me yeah
yeah that's interesting that you mentioned that I think like in the critical care transport in
the flight world I think like we've done a pretty decent job like encouraging everyone to do that
sort of stuff I see it less in the hospital and I have a theory that that's maybe just because
there's like it's a much more like hierarchical system in the hospital so like a junior provider
like doing something that seems unusual like there's like some resistance to that
whereas like in our setting like medics and nurses and whoever's like flying on the aircraft and
whatever program you're in the states for the most part like it's a pretty level playing field
so that that dynamic is maybe like attenuated or doesn't exist to some degree
um yeah I don't know I have to think about that one a little bit more have you have you noticed
that as well in the hospital like the things that are bread and butter to you as like as a provider
that you don't necessarily see like from what you've seen in transport versus hospital yeah yeah for
sure like a lot of like the like pre-oxidation stuff you were mentioning like you know getting a
patient's head of bed up pre-oxidating with like an OPA or NPA and using ethnic oxygenation like
we did that stuff religiously in the field yeah but I don't really see that often in the hospital
yeah I also think in general this is like maybe not totally related to events but like
like airway management is like a huge deal to us in the pre-hospital setting like we put a lot of
emphasis on it like we take a lot of pride in like doing that um whereas in the hospital like all the
clinicians it's just one of like a whole bunch of procedures they do and you always have like a team
of people like to back you up if things go wrong so I think there's like it seems like the urgency
to do the thing or maybe not the urgency because not like there's not a sense of urgency to get it
done but like maybe the the focus on it is less so like for us if we like take a second attempt
on an airway it's a big deal like in the hospital like I don't think anyone cares like it's fine
but like hey it was all right you like you didn't let the patient do you say that we bagged him like
try again but like for us we put like a lot of emphasis on that like first pass assess and I
think that's fine like I don't think there's anything wrong with it um I think it's just like
a difference of priorities like we have something to prove whereas like in the hospital they don't
maybe I'd like to think it matters though like the numbers in the studies say that the more attempts
you have the more negative outcomes but yeah I feel like we could talk about airway like all day
like it's a whole other totally whole other topic yeah we'll say that one for next time
I'm gonna get in trouble with all my RTs
another thing that we do or we talk a lot about in transport is clamping ET tubes
and I was curious to get your take on that and then yeah I'll spill the beans about what I see
like in the hospital side of things oh I see it all in the hospital side of things um yeah I feel
again like so first off I do have to say like when I teach clamping I am huge on teaching clamping
on exhalation and the reason for that is we're maintaining PEEP and it's yes like there is a lot
of depending on the machine you use and the mode of ventilation you use there's definitely pressure
control is never going to go beyond that peak pressure and there is often you know not necessarily
a huge concern whether you're clamping on inspiration but I always say for every single
ventilator if you don't know how your ventilator works and you don't know what mode of ventilation
the patient's going to be in on the other end if you're excuse me if you're in any other mode of
ventilation like a volume mode you can have those pressures go too high so with clamping on exhalation
you are ensuring you're not applying too much pressure to the lung to over to stand or cause
potentially a double stack of a breath and every ventilator works differently and I've had
ventilators before that if it's disconnects and it's on it's going to send pressure out that could
potentially before it connects and reads the pressure back it could expose the lung and we
don't really know so that being said there's that whole concern of well are we going we're going to
be losing pressure once we clamp and if we don't clamp at the end of inspiration our pressure is
going to drop lower but then I do have to say we're not carrying this is going to sound bad but
we're not carrying that much because if that's the truth that we're going to like absolutely
collapse and have our patient like completely de-recruit in a second we wouldn't be able to
suction our patients and we suction our patients and expose them to negative pressure which then
could cause de-recruitment and it does cause desaturation but they do recruit again so when
people talk about needing to give them a higher pressure when clamping and clamping at the end of
inspiration to ensure that during the transition they're not going to lose too much pressure I say
we'll do suction your patients so for safety to maintain as much peep as we can because they can
de-recruit and some ARDS patients are more sensitive or you know difficult to ventilate in
general hypoxia patients are more sensitive to de-recruitment I suggest clamping at the end of
exhalation for safety and the reason the reason I do that is just because you don't necessarily know
what mode of ventilation they're going to be in on the other end totally yeah and I think this is
something we've talked about before because I was always taught and teach to clamp on inhalation
for that reason we're lucky if you clamp it like we don't know if you like your clamps gonna hold
that seal like maybe it's like a slow leak but I think it does make sense like there is the risk
there that you can like stack like you're holding like peak pressure basically and then you're
giving another breath on top of that and we kind of talked about you could like get into the
needy gritty on this like if you had someone in a pressure control mode like
probably isn't that big of a deal because you're like pressure limited or if you like had them in
a volume control but you have like tight parameters set on your limits then it's also like a way to
mitigate that but I think that's maybe something I would like think about revisiting and like how I
teach that but in reality like I think you make a good point that like we break the circuit all
the time like in the hospital like we're breaking the circuit like a handful of times it shifts even
on like super sick RZ patients so part of me thinks that like maybe this like ET tube clamping thing
like doesn't matter it's something that we like routinely focus on in transport but to be honest
I've never seen anyone ever do it in the hospital so I was just like curious if that's a normal
finding or just an anomaly for me my practice is any patient who is on a peep greater than 10 it is
an absolute necessity to clamp when I'm transferring them for anything in hospital and as as best like
I would still argue for any patient that is on peeps that aren't just minimum there isn't a
harming clamping as long even for a patient who is awake and you can talk to them and explain what
you're about to do there's no harm in doing that clamping to maintain and I just I suggest just
decrease the time like make sure that it's a very quick procedure but for patients that do de-recruit
like why not why not clamp why put yourself like you're really shooting yourself in the face but
you know it's going to happen over time and that you're going to have de-recruitment specifically
with heterogeneous closing pressures of different alveoli there are more damage than others
and yes we may not maintain all of the pressure we may have some pressure loss but some pressure
maintained is better than none so I would still suggest why not yeah I think that's a good point
that like as long as you like mitigate the risk of like stacking another breath on top of like
a clamp so either by clamping an exhalation or making sure your pressure control or like having
your upper like your high pressure limit set tight as long as you do something to prevent
damage from it I think you can like advocate that you should do it across the board so yeah
I would agree with that um cool just carry on with our list here um what are your thoughts about
peep and fluid displacement like pushing fluid out of the lungs yeah this is a fun one right yeah
so I was taught back in the day that peep and pressure push fluid out of the lungs
um I now at this point the way I see it is it more that peep can help be a bit of a stop gap
to stop the leaking while the lymphatic system clears the fluid with like the shifts to like
hydrostatic fluid like pressures and all of those but at the end of the day realistically what we're
doing is we're just expanding the alveoli more to give more surface area there isn't a push of fluid
across that alveolar membrane it just the lymphatic system is what clears it more than anything
what are your thoughts yeah I agree with you yeah I think all of us were taught at one point
that like peep pushes fluid out of the alveoli it seems pretty clear that like
the benefit in terms of oxygenation is just increased surface area um but I think I'm not
totally convinced that like it doesn't help displace fluid to some degree but I think the
timeline is like much more prolonged than it like would matter in most transports like I think like
increasing surface area in the alveoli and like making the membrane thinner like a lot like would
allow that fluid to leave more quickly over time but I think it's like more prolonged thing like
my read of it is that like this is something that happens like over like hours to days not
something like you're not gonna like push all the fluid in a chf or as long as out in like 20 minutes
on the way to the hospital yeah and I think as well like if you are displacing fluid from the
alveoli where is it gonna go it's gonna sit in the alveolar capillary membrane like it's not
it's not going away and then there it's still impacting the ability of oxygen to diffuse so
realistically what needs to happen is you need to have the lymphatic system drain that fluid away
so the displacement won't help you at all because all it's going to do is still be sitting there
you know between the the capillaries and the alveoli so even though it may displace it out of
the lung alveoli slightly it's not displaced out of the entire system so it's still working against
you so realistically the body needs to clear that and PEEP allows you know potentially less
leaking into the lungs and that can then over time be cleared so that like that's kind of how
if you really want to get into how I currently now think of it in my mind that's like that's
kind of more of how I think about it but now I try to just really focus more on like
we're increasing surface area to allow more you know area for gas exchange to occur and then
like we're not necessarily pushing the fluid out but totally yeah and I think in general like
that maybe just because like the transition from like working as like a ground medic to critical
care but I think that understanding of the concept is definitely like is now presented differently
than when I was first learning this sounds like maybe the same for you absolutely and there's
there's so many things like that that I I was taught you know when I was newer to the
career that I've relearned over the years or like learned in a different frame or a different form
and it's crazy how all of that can you know change over the span of just a few years like
I've only been practicing now 17 years and like I feel like what I learned back then is so vastly
different to now yeah yeah I think that yeah I think that's bound to happen with time
um what are your thoughts on like a hypotensive ventilator strategy like doing things on the vent
to like yeah I think everyone like agrees that like putting somebody on positive pressure
mechanical ventilation can like decrease blood return to the heart and cause them to become
hypotensive but what about like intentionally using event strategy in a hypotensive patient
to like prevent it from happening to whatever degree you can yeah and I think you were referring
to a specific strategy right when like was the question yeah so um basically you would use like
a higher tidal volume and a lower rate so you like basically like decrease the amount of time
when you're pushing air into the lungs above your peep and then you could potentially even like
drop your peep to zero so like the I guess like the most extreme version of this would be like
have a tidal volume is like high as you deem safe for your patient with a rate as low as you can to
maintain whatever you think is a minimum ventilation and then leave your peep at zero
mm-hmm and that would be like the the least impact you could have on like blood return to the heart
on preload yeah because it's like less time under extreme pressure kind of idea and then like no
pressure yeah I I looked into it I actually tried to look at some of the studies because it I'll be
honest I'll be very honest like I don't know close to enough about everything and I feel like the more
I hear I'm like I've never heard of that before I'd never heard of this before um so in my career
I've never used a strategy like this ever other than just focusing on diminishing or decreasing
peep as much as possible and to be fair we never really have to because we in most clinical
settings we have access to other things like we can give fluids and pressers and like yeah we can
do all the other but like there is like a subset of like clinicians out there who work in like
resource limited settings where like they may not have access to that stuff or maybe like on the way
later yeah and I think that that's a valid point because I I'll whenever I hear about hypovolemia or
like different strategies for that I always say well like fix the problem like try to support the
heart support the blood like the blood pressure and whatever means you can that's appropriate
to the type of shock that you have in order to then be able to ventilate the patient appropriately
so I guess like my my concern with the idea of like you know hyper low rates and larger volumes
like in the one study I read they used volumes that were well beyond um what is deemed you know
quote unquote safe in some like in the schools of like arts net studies that we've had from 25
years ago now of like you know 12 mils per kilo was the study that I read they used which
my concern with that would be what are the plateau pressures that that lung is experiencing
and then with that you are then going down to zero peep completely collapsing the alveoli and
then the shearing forces and the driving pressures that you're then experiencing to reopen those
alveoli from completely nothing like when you just think about the compliance of the lung in that
very low period if you're not adding peep that's the time where you're going to need a lot more
pressure in order to open so you're you are exposing those lungs to probably more pressure
than you know I would like to see and then and I wonder over for these patients that are
potentially bleeding and potentially in a traumatic arrest they're already at an increased risk
risk of ARDS and then you're potentially going to be exposing them to these large pressures
it makes me nervous like I would definitely I I feel like I need to read more about it and to
talk to people with larger brains than mine to explain their rationale and to show me how they
think that this would still be lung protective for the patient I would still argue you know keep your
peeps low keep your pressures on the lower side and you'd really have to show me and convince me
that like high high pressures and high volumes that you're going to be experiencing these large
areas would actually show you over time you know a significant amount of lowered pressure over time
to then show an improvement with blood pressure so that's kind of like my roundabout answer yeah
I think that's the part that is like kind of a big unknown at the moment it's like it makes intuitive
sense that this would like potentially like mitigate that effect of like dropping preload
in a mechanically ventilated patient but like at what cost and that's like that's the unknown part
like at what point does it like not become in the patient's benefit to do that kind of thing
and like I said like we could almost always like leave the vent strategy alone and use other
interventions to increase like to address the hypotension so it's not really like a
does much matter for most of us like where we practice but it's more of like a question just
like in the worst case scenario like if you're out straight or not island and all you have is your
ventilator which doesn't really happen to most of us but that's hey you know have a ventilatable
travel why not I had a bbm in my car for like years and years and years before I finally was
like okay the expiry date is really past the point that I would ever want to use this and also now I'm
like I don't really know I want to have this in my car because then I feel like I have to use it
yeah anyways so I know but I I would need to read more for sure like it's it's an interesting idea
but like hey like pre-hospital blood I'm on the train too everyone should have it yeah for sure
um you have mentioned a couple times in some of your posts about going with a
tidal volume of eight mils per kilo versus six you want to talk about that a bit yeah um so
for arts patients that is the one population and I'm speaking about adult ventilation here
but um for a or ds patients or patients that are showing evidence that you're dealing with
a or ds that's the one patient population well I would say start at six but when it comes to
any other patient pathology and even when you look at ARDSnet protocol as long as like if you
had a patient that was acidotic that as long as you had room in your plateau pressures ARDSnet
protocol taught you to go up to eight mils per kilo it would tell you to increase your
tidal volumes um by one mil per kilo until you got to eight mils per kilo and that is part of
ARDSnet protocol like that is six to eight mils per kilo within the protocol that we've been using
but everyone kind of micro focuses on the six which again that is the initial settings for ARDS
but for everybody else we know that eight as long as your driving pressures and plateau pressures
are within range it gives you a much more effective alveolar ventilation this is you know
just basic physiology we know we have dead space and now with the emergence of you know a bunch of
literature looking at intermediate tidal volumes there is this whole idea of this driving pressure
you know targeted tidal volumes that for patients that have higher compliant lungs that they really
can get larger tidal volumes some of the studies are going well beyond eight mils per kilo
as long as your driving pressure is safe and you know sub 14 15 14 and in that range there
so again i teach if you have room with your driving pressure and plateau pressure consider
and you need to normalize gases consider going up to eight mils per kilo and the new body of research
looking at mechanical power and like all these things are starting to like bring all these other
ideas into the picture where we know that tidal volumes keeping them low is not the only piece of
the puzzle anymore and if you just think about it intuitively like if we are banging the crap of
our lungs open and closed every single time we do that that's going to cause trauma we know that so
it's not just the amount of volumes not just the amount of pressure it could also be the rate and
it could also be just the amount of power that we're pushing into the lungs from the vent so
there is more to the picture and i'm not teaching beyond eight at all and please don't misunderstand
me and if your patient has ARDS i still abide by the idea of starting at six mils but if you have
the ability and you need to normalize gases going with a larger volume and getting to eight mils per
kilo if it's safe with safe pressures it's going to be more effective and then when you're
let's say like hypothetical we started a patient on six mils per kilo and then the driving pressure
is like 10 and that plateau is obviously fine you're going up to eight and then you're just
stopping there or do you ever find a reason to go past that if the driving pressure is still low
great question as of now i am still maxing myself at eight mils per kilo and and that we don't have
enough evidence yet but to go beyond that in my in my opinion to for me to change my practice beyond
that like i think the prevent trial was a really great study to start to look at that and to look
at the intermediate volumes but we still just we don't have enough i know that eight mils per kilo
is safe and i know that it is even safe in ARDS patients and until we have more data to show that
for sure you know in non-ARDS patients going up to x number of mils per kilogram of predictive
body weight with x driving pressure and x mechanical power is safe as well i i don't
think that i'm ready to get there but i think the next few years are going to be really really
interesting um like just to remind people like if you go back because there's going to be some that
listen to this so probably it's gonna it's gonna irk them but if you go back to the ARDS net study
back from that everything is based on it compared six mils per kilogram of predicted body weight to
12 mils per kilogram of predictive body weight there was no in between and the ARDS net protocol
went to six to eight so that is all safe we know that's safe and now we're looking at the 10 to 12
range and what that means and again i'm not there yet i'm not doing that yet but who knows where the
next few years will take us okay and then a follow-up question so let's say we start someone on
tidal volume of six mils per kilo and we like did all of our math so we come up to like a rate of 16
or 17 and then we increase our tidal volume up to eight mils per kilo and we're still safe
but now our minute volume is a little higher than our initial goal and we say our end tidal
start to drop we're down to 30 what do you do excellent question and i think here it depends
a lot on what's the patient doing it depends a lot on like you know your sedation and kind of your
your environment are you in transport are you not because i think at that point you can choose
if your patient is breathing and their intrinsic respiratory rate is on the higher end then i would
probably drop my tidal volume but if my patient isn't then you know at that point both numbers
are safe you can choose i probably would still suggest dropping your tidal volume down because
why not it'll mean less pressure to the lungs less pressure is a good thing and your rates aren't high
but if the situation was that i was at eight mils per kilo and a higher rate i probably would
come down on my rate if i was at a rate of like 26 or something and that's i guess the art versus i
like there i'm like there's no right wrong answer pick an answer and try it right on one other thing
i wanted to mention ryan um is like back to the situation of like trying to get to eight mils like
before i'll i'll increase my pressures or um you know if i was in like a prvc mode like increase
my volumes right away for the vent to then decide or whatever or no volume control mode i would
probably optimize my inspiratory time if i have a ventilator that i have that option so if i'm on
a mode that has a ti if i'm in a pressure mode of any kind i would look to optimize time and use time
to my favor and see if i can potentially get more volume with the same amount of pressure
before i even go to increase pressures that's kind of one great tool that you can do as well
in order to optimize that so i'm sure you know ryan but others might not totally and just to
like clarify that point so you're saying if you have somebody who were currently the way we have
the vent set up we're getting that six mils per kilo and you're trying to get more volume per
breath like closer to eight you would just prolong your inspiratory time yeah and it doesn't always
work like you have to look at your waveforms and this is where like i am a huge proponent for if
you're using a ventilator you need to you need to dive into waveforms because that is everything um
and i again i feel like i'm preaching to someone that knows this so um when it comes to looking at
your inspiratory flow time curve if you see that your inspiratory flow is not coming down to zero
before the breath cycles into exhalation because remembering that in any pressure mode that has an
inspiratory time your cycling mechanism is your inspiratory time so if you are able to extend that
inspiratory time you will then get more volume but if your flow comes down to zero and you extend
your your inspiratory time you're going to end up with an inspiratory zero flow hold which will not
give you more volume so you have to know your waveform to look at your inspiratory waveform to
be able to see whether time will work in your favor or not so normally the classic picture is
you'll see your your peak inspiratory flow you'll see your flow start to decay on that that
decelerating slope that you see but then before it comes it cuts off and just falls off click
and if you see that then you know that you had accessible flow you should see that float time
waveform coming close to zero um to be able to determine whether increasing time will be working
your favor or not right yeah and this is something that's cool now that um the price point has really
come down on the hamilton and everyone seems to be using those in transport like all over the world
uh it's now that we have access to those like waveforms and loops which is pretty cool
yeah oh you said loops oh right loops do you use the lifts on the hamilton t1 uh we i mean we look
at them the thing is i'm not convinced that maybe i just don't know enough about it but i think
the loops give you information that you can also get elsewhere yes so i'm not i'm not convinced that
like you should go looking for the shapes of your loops to like make a diagnosis but it can confirm
something you know or you can like see in real time as you're doing an intervention but i don't
know if i would like start there to go like troubleshooting what's going on with my patient
yeah a little pearl that i eventually i will get my instagram posts to this point where i'm
going to go through this and go on a rant about it if you're using the hamilton t1 and you are
using your pressure volume loops you're you don't you don't know what you're looking at and i say
that with all the love in the world and don't worry because like i didn't have a good understanding
either when i graduated as an rt um remember that the hamilton t1 is a pressure ventilator so the
idea with your pressure volume loop the best mode of ventilation to be able to look at a pressure
volume loop and get information out of it is when you need a ventilator where everything is
consistent except for one variable so a volume control mode where volume is consistent per breath
and flow is controlled will give you pressure being the variable that is changing so with the
loops then you can look for your opening pressures your closing pressures you can look for over
distention and yes it's a bit hand wavy with opening pressures and closing pressures on which
one we use and all those things but looking for those inflection points like really it has it has
to be a volume control mode so on the hamilton 2.1 we we know we don't have a true volume control
mode we are using a pressure mode of ventilation regardless and since pressure is limited and
volume is changing and flow is changing you blow past your inflection points with your pressures
with it being a pressure mode too quickly because the vent is just cycling up and then it's
flattening your curve right when realistically you'd be getting your information about over
distention because we're limiting pressure so with that you lose all of that great information so
at that point all you're left with is leaks which you can see elsewhere spontaneous efforts you can
see elsewhere and then also you're missing everything else that you could use them for
so you would maybe look at a loop on you'd like in a hospital setting like where I work like
everyone is in volume control ventilation with a volume control like a true volume control
ventilator but not so much with pressure control unless you're just like dirtying out and trying
to confirm what you think you already know yeah and I tend to even I don't use even loops that
much in volume control but I would use it more so when it comes to like looking for the beaking for
example that would show you over distention that's something that is very handy to look at for a
volume control mode but again you'll never see that with with a pressure control
mode of ventilation which is what we have on the health and t1 yeah I've only ever used them more
for like curiosity's sake like oh like this is what I think is going on with the patient
I remember like what the shape is supposed to look like so then you like pull it up you're like
oh yeah cool yeah maybe not the one thing that one of my amazing co-workers she teaches when she
talks about loops is really the only thing you're really looking at is like the upright football
means a more compliant lung so if the football drops to the side and it's a horizon then you have
a less compliant line but then you can look at your page three monitoring just look at your c-stat in
real time so there isn't enough value to lose both my you know flow time waveform and my volume
waveform like keep your flow time waveform up on the screen is what I always tell people yeah I
think most people are just like pulling it up to like take it well that's what I do I just like
pull it up and take a peek at it and like flip through and like look at all the cool things that
the Hamilton gives you like look at your dynamic lung like your loops and then you like put it
back on your home screen because that's where you like need to keep an eye on things yeah yeah I get
yeah so you mentioned looking at your um like using your waveforms to adjust your inspiratory
time um to decide if you can like give more or less time um to maximize that tidal volume
what do you think if you had to like pick a couple of like important things for
folks in transport to be able to like pick out of the waveforms at a glance what's another thing
or two you would put on that list gas trapping like that's like hands down so just making sure
like it like gets back to your set peep yeah so making sure your flow time waveform it comes and
even like your pressure waveforms like that's not a good place to look at for auto peeping
because the vent is going to show you on that pressure waveform whatever you've set it won't
read accurately um the pressures when it comes to i know and this is if you read in that manual
auto peeping is a wild thing um and uh it's a little bit of a soapbox again i can get on
yeah because i was always taught to like keep an eye on the
pressure waveform to see if it comes back to your set peep yes but it's
saying it may still show that it gets the peep but it's not actually all the way there yes
interesting so when i teach even like on patreon monitoring we have auto peep is something we can
read i don't trust that that is grain of salt grain of salt it's based on your settings and
it's something that is calculated but especially when you have auto peeping in the lung it is a
dynamic process that is not happening homogeneously through that lump so with that unless you can do a
true expiratory hold to then get equilibration of pressure and actually read what is being felt with
auto peeping if it quacks like a duck meaning if you see on your expiratory flow waveform that
you're not getting back to zero you have auto peep regardless of what your pressure waveform says
regardless of what auto peeping you have on the other end that expiratory flow time waveform is
the bible that you need to follow when it comes to looking for auto peep and until that flow time
waveform comes back to zero treat it like you're still auto peeping because it's going to underestimate
in every other aspect what your auto peep is so you could have just to like reiterate this point
because this is something that is new to me you could have your pressure time waveform drop back
to whatever baseline you have set as peep and still have and your on your like other pages in
your monitoring on the hamilton it could say like auto peep is zero but if you're seeing that the
flow time the flow waveform doesn't come all the way back to zero you could still have some degree
of auto peep in certain regions of the lung yes and to clarify normally what will happen is that
your auto peep will be reading like point two something very very small um but your your
expiratory flow time waveform is not coming back to zero and what i can guarantee you even if you
froze your waveform and you scrolled back and you were reading your pressure and it's saying that
you're reading like pretty much five point five point one five point two that is underestimating
that is underestimating a thousand percent that auto peep reading that it's saying is point two
is probably a lot higher than that and it's going to continue getting worse and you can see this in
the manual if you read through the t1 manual it says clearly multiple times that auto peep is
estimated and that it should not be counted on when it comes to this and there's also some really
great studies i can actually send them to you after i'll look them up and send them to you
that talk about the fact that unless you're doing a true expiratory hold auto peep is always
underestimated so using that flow time waveform as what grounds you as like there is auto peep and
it's worse than i think and fix it fix it fix it right on and how much of a like
trying to think of like how to ask this question like how much of a disparity
is there like we often teach it like a couple points of auto peep it's like not a big deal as
long as they're not like seeing an increase like as long as they're seeing a significant change
so would you like always act on not seeing your flow time waveform your flow all would
come all the way back to zero would you like just note it and see if it changing it's worse or would
you always address it and get it back to zero i always try to fix auto peep that is that is my
my core in my body because it's hard to really tell until you know later on now there are
situations where the patient is doing it themselves specifically you can think about you know obese
patients or COPD patients where they end up doing it a little bit so in those cases i'm not too
worried but in like an asthmatic or a COPD even then i will still try to fix it by decreasing
my rates if my rates are greater than you know 10 and i'm still seeing that full-time waveform
come back to zero i am decreasing my rates so it's hard it's hard to say like because there isn't
like one size fits all usually i will always act on a full-time waveform that is not coming back
to zero unless i have already got them down to again like sub 10 in my respiratory rate and i'm
still there and the patient is seeming to be stable and i'm still like going down every other
route of trying to treat it in every way that i possibly can yeah yeah that makes sense
cool anything else on the waveforms oh my gosh so much i feel like i could talk about waveforms
i think those are like too good those are like two easy things to see yes just like yeah like
you can see in a glance you don't have to like yeah seem to like look too hard and then i like
another one is leaks um and i have like all these things as well i have videos on my instagram that
kind of go through them for those that are listening that you can go and i walk you through
auto peeping and leaks and how to recognize them and all these different things and just the basics
of the waveforms in general and um and i am at some point in the near future starting to move
into all the worlds of the different asynchronies or dysynchronies however you like to say it that
exist and how to recognize them and what to do about it and what they mean um and trying to again
just do it in a way that makes sense and is really easy and approachable to understand
and it really isn't that hard once you know what to look for so like i would say the three major
things are that auto peeping with your expiratory waveform leaks to be able to recognize them
because they can really screw up what you're reading and what you're seeing remembering as
well the volumes you're seeing specifically on the t1 but most ventilators the volumes you see on your
main monitoring panel is expired volumes and so a lot of people don't understand that if they have
a leak in place that the volumes they're delivering are probably they are higher than that and they
could be beyond what is safe especially when it gets to the tiny humans and ventilating the babies
um and if they have an uncuffed tube like this is very important when you're dealing with the
mode of ventilation that you're in and all those things yeah and just to clarify this point because
i think that's a really good point is that when you're when you're measuring your exhaled volume
it's only what comes out of the tube yes like you could put like 700 mils in and you only see 500
of it come out of the tube because the rest leaks around so you could end up like giving a lot more
air than you that you think yes yeah and every modern ventilator should have a way for you to
look through your monitoring to see what volume went in and the vent will read it but just
recognizing that what is on the main screen as the default one you see um from every ventilator i've
ever worked with and there's a lot of them it's always expired and and that's always something
that kind of shocks people and like if you're dealing with uh cmv plus on the hamilton t1 or
what's the other name for an apb cmv or something um that is a volume target mode that is targeting
exhaled volumes and going to deliver pressures to hit that exhaled volume so leaks will work
against you if you're not able to recognize them and it's a very easy thing to see and to be able
to then act on yeah i think the only exception in terms of ventilators that we still see out there
that don't have a flow sensor to measure an exhaled volume would be the uh what's the new name for the
the zho emv or the old egomed those ones don't have a sensor to measure like exhaled flow but
those are mostly getting phased out but we still see this sometimes well and hey not knocking
vents that don't have a proximal flow sensor at the patient i've used with many of them and like
my absolute favorite ventilator i've ever used rip pb 840 i loved you did not have a flow sensor
at the patient and it read the volumes back at the vent and that vent was brilliant i loved it so
much it's gone now i'm still crying about it but um the vents are still great but they they still
are reading what's coming back to the machine to then tell you on that main screen and i didn't get
to my third thing but to say really quickly is auto triggering that's the other thing that everyone
should be able to recognize in the waveform right on and we'll direct everyone to your videos if
they're not familiar with that yes i go through all the different causes cool um how are we doing
on time do you still have time yeah why not all right um for troubleshooting what are your thoughts
on the dope mnemonic i love it i do suggest the dopes with the s's as many s's as you can fit on
the end um because i think there is a lot of issues that come with ventilation when it comes to
synchronizing um and i don't like the s being sedation i like the s being synchronizing if you
have the ability to change your ventilation even in micro amounts to make it more comfortable to
mean less sedation that is um something that i would really strongly you know recommend for
practitioners as the next frontier in their ventilation skills it might not be your first
level but once you're comfortable where you are then starting to learn about trying to you know
look for those signs in the waveforms telling your patients uncomfortable it'll mean less sedation
which will then mean a better blood pressure which will then mean less inotropes or vasopress
and like it feeds into a much happier transport for you not just yeah yeah this is something that
like when i was putting the vent book together like a lot of how i talked about like adjusting
things on the ventilator for patient comfort was more of like trying things and seeing if it works
because this was like before the hamilton was like readily available so it's something i need
to like revisit like how to present that idea now that you have like data to look at whereas
like you know like sometimes you have somebody who like tolerates being in like volume control
this is like pre-hamilton days just fine and other patients like they're really uncomfortable
on it but you put them in pressure control and it works and like prior to waveforms or like without
waveforms like it's kind of like hard to like you're just like kind of guessing and trying different
things but i think now there's maybe a better way to present that where you're like looking for
specific things and making changes based on that such as like you know like having a strategy for
like how you're adjusting your inspiratory time or yeah that's something i need to like maybe like
look back over on the next version like refine a little bit especially like almost everyone now is
using the t1 so we have like a lot more data than we did before yeah and that frontier i think is
is such a like it it is my favorite realm of ventilation it's an area that i am still
like daily obsessed with and i'm reading about and feel like i am nowhere near the pinnacle of what
i can possibly learn and and i do want to just encourage everybody that feels a bit overwhelmed
that like this was not stuff that was covered very well when i went to rt school like that was
you know 18 19 okay yeah now almost 20 years ago that i started my rt school and that like
vents were just starting to have waveforms i was still working with ventilators in an icu that did
not have a screen that had numerics just like you would have seen like the ltv that like spit out
across the screen and you just scroll through so um waveforms were the next level and some vents
had them some did not and then starting work and starting my clinical yes most vents did but then
it wasn't something that really was fit into the program very well and i know a lot of rts that are
graduating it's still something that they don't feel was covered as well so it's something that
a lot of rts are still learning as well so don't feel like it's scared too far too outside the
realm of you know what you could know it's not it's actually once you understand what you're
looking for and once you can recognize normal that is where you start recognizing normal and
then recognizing when something is does not look normal and then the rest is gravy you just start
to look at your patients and and why would your flows go up or down what could be happening and
then it all falls from there yeah yeah it totally makes sense i'm the same thing like that's kind of
how we or at least when i was learning ekgs we taught in the same way like you need to look at
like do 12 leads on all your patients for the first year or two so you can like identify what's
normal then when you see something funky you may not know what it is but you're like okay like
i gotta figure this out because like something is not normal yeah yeah i mean that's a good approach
um just to loop back to the the dope question the reason i ask that question is because i
tend to be like a anti-dope mnemonic person um i think i'm like anti-nemonics in general because
i think like a lot of times we have so many to remember and then you know like oftentimes you
can like remember the letters but you don't actually like remember what they stand for i
think they can like they can like hang you up a little bit we also like i have noticed in
transport we tend to like teach that the dope mnemonic addresses like all the possible problems
you could run into with ventilation which is definitely not true um so yeah like i sometimes
i'm not convinced that it's like the best framework for like approaching problems but i think like as
long as you're aware of the limitations that you can take totally fine to use um i just yeah i think
we sometimes assume it is like a yeah an all descriptive like recipe for figuring out what's
going on with the ventilator and it's not necessarily the case uh i i agree with you 100
like uh like to be very transparent the last time i actually thought about dopes in my actual practice
oh i don't even i i can't remember i can't remember and it's like now when i walk to a
bedside i am using my eyes i am using my hands and i am using like i i can i can look in the
waveform and know what's going on like pretty much if you show me a waveform i can tell you what's
wrong like like the ventilator like it's very easy to tell i can feel the circuit and i and
i know whether i need to suction my patient like it's i can look at my patient how they're
breathing and see the problem so you you evolve past that but sometimes in in a time of cognitive
load like having the dopes pneumonic to fall back on um especially if you're nearing a journey i'll
never knock it never not once because i think it will save a lot of people in a situation of like
i don't know what to do well one of the s's is sedation so i can't fix this i don't know what's
wrong so okay i guess we're at the point where we're calling for paralysis and extra and more
sedation and that's okay like safety is paramount and and we need to be safe for our patients and
if you don't know what's going on disconnect and beg if you can't fix the problem or you know it's
not begging and it's the patient fighting then there is always other things you can do in order
to to fix it so i don't know i think people do evolve past the pneumonics i very much agree with
you and i think there is a point where it doesn't serve the purpose anymore but i will never knock
someone for needing it or needing to rely on it yeah totally same thing like i don't yeah like in our
emt or like even first responder classes we teach like this thing called decaf btls like
yeah all of the injuries you can see when they like during your assessment like yeah everyone
like memorize that but eventually you get to a point where you like you don't actually like
need to rehearse and out loud every time you like assess a patient yes absolutely um
you talked already about um you mentioned it twice like paralysis and transport
um i think that's worth like discussing a little bit more um i think there's generally like mixed
opinions on this like one take is that um we shouldn't paralyze our patients because we want
to support spontaneous ventilation um and there's like a whole bunch of advantages to that and then
the other side is that you are also responsible for keeping that tube where it belongs like in the
correct spot and paralyzing them allows you to do that better
i'm just curious to know you like your thoughts in transport what your practice is when you were
flying i can count on less than three fingers how many patients that i personally paralyzed in
transport um i do have to preface this with the fact that in my flight environment that i worked
we were um like pre pre-hospital flying up to remote communities that we did not do a lot of
ift transfers like from facility to facility so i'm sure they're with doing inter-facility
transports i probably would have come across when more patients who are already paralyzed or already
further along in the course of their disease that they would have required paralysis but of the
patients that i transported and a lot of them vented for long periods like i always try to
gently remind people like that some of the transports i did was upwards of greater than
seven hours i was flying insane distances um and i didn't have to rely on that i flew in a lot of
extreme weather conditions and there were times that i had to give a lot of sedation or give a
bolus but i i tended not to fall on um paralysis now again i i said this as well before but i'll
say it again i will never knock a provider for going to paralysis if there is a concern
there is a degree of comfort that i have with being able to recognize when a patient starts
to rouse and wake up i can see it in the ventilator in the waveform and i also always always always
carried very very easily accessible medications to deepen them um and also pre-dose them when it
was coming to a situation about going into minus 80 degree wind shells which i would be exposing
them to so um all this to say that's how many times i've done it in my practice i don't think
it's needed as much as it's done but again if it comes down to safety as the need i would never
question a decision yeah i'm kind of the same way like very rarely will paralyze a patient
um but that said like i i think there's like the maybe a misunderstanding that like paralyzing a
patient is like dangerous for the patient um and i think sometimes that maybe is like a little bit
overblown like i think it's it's totally fine in most cases i could be paralyzed a patient to get
them through like bumpy sectional road or why you're like loading them like i think it's yeah
like i think in like in years past i would have maybe had like stronger opinions on that like
oh like don't do that because we want like salvage whatever like spontaneous effort they have
but i think like with time i've kind of realized that like it's probably just fine
and i think the caveat i would say on the other end is like going back to the beginning when i
talked about like my job as an RT is to get someone off of the ventilator as quick as possible
i i really did fly by that mantra as well and like the other side of dropping a patient off
at a hospital is something that a lot of people in transport don't necessarily see and i can i can
truly say especially when receiving a patient from a critical care flight team i'm not going
to change their settings i'm going to copy their settings whatever they're on and i'm going to put
the patient on the same settings and if they're paralyzed that means they're on a control mode and
then by the time the nurses do the bed move and they you know get the patient settled and they get
all the monitors on and i'm allowed to go back into the bedside to even get a gas or ask for a gas or
have a gas drawn most likely the actual timeline after the patient arrives in the hospital that
they are going to have a vent change done is going to be at least four hours later if not potentially
a little longer there are some hospitals that don't wean on nights and don't make changes on
nights like i see there's a whole range of things so whatever length your transport was if
they were paralyzed even with the paralysis waking up if they turn the paralysis off and lighten them
it's going to be a lot longer clinically for that patient to be on a ventilator versus if they were
in a control mode and breathing above and they got transferred over and that stimulation made
them breathe a couple more points as an RT at the bedside i might be like i'm gonna slip into
the brush sport and see what they do so that might then accelerate that patient by two three days
yeah that's a significant time yeah
so it's is it harmful no safety in transport is paramount and i agree with you it's not going to
hurt your patient to paralyze them and if it makes it safer then absolutely do it 100 um but if it
means getting that patient off the ventilator even one day sooner that's something to think about it's
food for thought if there's a way to do it safely right on i just had one other thing to chat about
um what do you know about volumetric kenography not a heck of a lot you threw that question at
the end and i was like oh like i'll be honest but i like i like the question i didn't tell you i
didn't want to talk about it because a i think it's important to really stress the fact that i
don't know everything i've read i read a little bit of the studies on it and i say
it looks kind of cool i'm i'm intrigued i'm interested i'd like to see more um
to or and probably get my hands on it and play with it a bit have you had to use it i only have
like read about it um but i have a like my understanding of like the tech and i guess
maybe we could give like a little bit of background but the idea here is that you could measure
like the the quantity of co2 that is exhaled instead of like the way we do kenography you're
just measuring like um like a peak concentration you could actually measure like in milliliters or
liters like how much oxygen is being exhaled with a breath or over like a given amount of time
and i think the advantage if i recall right it's been a while since i looked into this is that
would allow you to uh accurately measure what dead space like what the patient's dead space is
yes and i think that provides a lot of value because dead space is kind of this like
elusive like complicated idea that like makes mechanical ventilation like really intimidating
for a lot of people um but i think we tend to like uh like overthink the problem like there
are some things we can do in transport or even at bedside to like minimize the effect and after that
like that's that's kind of what we can do but i think being able to see it in real time like when
you pop whatever little gadget you have in the vent circuit out and see how it changes i think
like something like that would be like highly advantageous even if you didn't have it like
on all the patients you're paneling but like if it was available in sim labs or even like on non
evasive so you can like demonstrate to somebody like i think that technology would be like really
good for like learning and teaching even if you didn't have it for every patient i think it i think
it would really help um give a number to those people that need numbers in order to have them
start to like flex their their targets when it comes to ventilation and really drive home the
point that sometimes a slightly larger breath and a slightly lower rate is more effective and if you
look at the math it makes sense that like you are actually clearing co2 at a better rate um so i think
it would it would help for those people that struggle with that that like don't understand
i don't understand i'm increasing my respiratory rate and my co2s aren't coming down why not and
it's like because you're barely changing anything because the volumes you're giving are like barely
clearing dead space so it would help um i think the the thing that also gives you that value
already and not a quantifiable not like a number that you can actually look at and like hold in your
hands and tangibly and say like this is how much of my volume is getting in but like when you
correlate your gases to your end title you're already really looking at that relationship and
seeing the like how much of an issue you have in vq matching and that then can lead you down the
path of like can we optimize this in any way and can we improve um and then kind of lead you down
the path of like is people going to work in our favor or not using physiology as your grounding so
but i like the idea of a number for those people that need it in order to be able to start to
ventilate more effectively yeah and i think the point you make about gases definitely makes sense
but in transport we oftentimes like we don't have that or we have like a single data point like even
places that are doing gases they they will do one maybe like a second one on arrival but like in
the hospital setting you can like get those every four hours for like you know you might have the
same vented patient for like three days so you can like trend it and see how it goes um but that's
something that like a lot of folks in transport just like never have had access to they just
it's like out of our yeah not really out of our i don't know what it is we just don't see patients
for that period of time like you're not able to appreciate those trends um but something like
being able to like yeah like eventually i think the tech will be there where you just like your
end title detector on your monitor will like measure that capnography like in terms of a volume
not just like a a single number um i imagine that will exist something i think the dead space
specifically is going to be a like a benefit i really do um i just i think i do want to see it
a bit more in use and like maybe studied against like those patients where we're using blood gases
because i i would love to see the value of having every service that has ventilators have a point of
care machine because i think there is value in actually targeting and chasing the number that
you should be chasing instead of um a bad reflection that sometimes doesn't even reflect
the thing you should be chasing so like at the end of the day ph is what we want not pco2 and
not end title co2 like ph is where we want to be and if you don't know what core what compensation
your patient has and what process like you could be chasing a completely different animal and um
so i think like i would love to throw my support behind something like that and yes the machines
are finicky i stat versus epoch i've used them both and both have their drawbacks um but like
it's still such that the value you get back is so high um so that's kind of my my stance not but
i'm curious to see where the volumetric end title goes yeah and i think even for places that don't
like carry their own i stats like a lot of hospitals now like have like point of care tests
like in the isus or in the gem machine yeah yeah like a gem so you even if it's not like part of
your like programs capabilities you can still like they're gonna run a gem as soon as that patient
gets set up so just like hang around for 15 minutes and like take a look at it and then you can like
get an idea like yeah it's like ventilating my patient to this like go away and title
and then i like look at their gas and they're actually like oh man they're like ph like
got worse like maybe i should have ventilated them to like a lower goal you know like you can
like adjust your strategy a little bit um just with that like receiving hospitals data point
even if it's not part of like you are like what you're doing clinically yeah absolutely it changes
changes what you're targeting for sure yeah yeah cool well that's all of my questions is there
anything else that you wanted to mention or that you honestly like i feel like we could talk all
day like there's there's so many things and i think this was a this was fun like we had some
tech issues in the beginning but it was it was a lot of fun we figured it out we did and i feel
like i don't know enough about you ryan but i feel like i won't bore your for the podcast with asking
you questions about you instead i'll just bunny you on instagram but like perfect for everyone
just that's listening um if you want to follow me if you're interested in hearing more and like
feel free i i love being a resource um and you can find me on melodybishop underscore rt um
but otherwise i tested that because she puts up with all my questions
i i really do like i just i want to be a friendly neighborhood rt that people aren't scared of
asking anything that they think is a stupid question but i can guarantee you it isn't stupid
because i've asked way stupider ones in my in my life so it is i just want to be an easily
accessible and friendly person that you'll never feel stupid to reject too awesome we appreciate that